[Applause]
[Music]
after a harrowing chase ethic hedge and
their new ally Lema find themselves in a
cavernous control room
here the last artifact the node of
memory is suspended within a force field
and powering a supercomputer ethic is
about to deactivate the force field when
Lema stops her she explains a decade ago
she was assigned a research task to use
the world machine to create something
that would make everyone happy after
many failed attempts lemma discovered a
compound that when ingested made people
motivated happy creative loving in short
their best selves it was rushed into
production soon the entire nation's food
supply came from Huck's and Borg with
the compound mixed in the first year was
paradise the second not so much
side-effects began to emerge
memory loss listlessness and self
absorption in the third year the
government dissolved leaving the robots
running everything in a self-sustaining
loop by this point things were too far
gone for lemma to reverse people had
become dependent on the compound and the
few who refused it formed a resistance
to try to fix things it took 10 years
for lemma to find a cure this Factory
contains everything she'll need to make
it but the second they take the note of
memory the security system will alert
the robots and they'll have to run if
instead they first reconfigure the
factory to manufacture the cure the
people can be saved lemma has the whole
Factory redesign planned out the problem
is it's a little hard to read her
schematic shows all the steps in the
manufacturing process needed to make the
cure an arrow from add nitric acid to
shake vigorously means that the acid
addition has to happen before shaking if
a single step is performed out of order
the Cure won't work or worse there
aren't any circular references where
step a requires step B and step be
eventually requires step a
[Music]
here's where ethic and hedge come in
lemma needs hedge to translate the
tangled diagram into a sequence of steps
that'll be the order that things happen
in the factory once input into the
central computer the factory will
reassemble itself as instructed hedges
ability to store information in a table
will help here so how does ethic program
hedge to turn out a correct sequence
that can reconfigure the factory
[Music]
it may help to first think about this
problem as a human rather than a machine
given this diagram it's clear to start
with getting a bowl since no arrows
point to it how might you mark up the
diagram to figure out what to do next
diagrams like the one lemma has drawn
are called directed acyclic graphs a
graph is a representation of data that
shows different elements and how they're
related to each other
directed means that direction matters as
indicated by the arrows here a leads to
B but B doesn't lead to a and acyclic
means that there aren't any loops which
is fortunate because if there were this
problem wouldn't be solvable there's a
simple way to navigate the graph as a
human start with a step that doesn't
have any arrows pointing to it once you
do that cross out that step and all
arrows leading from it choose another
step with no arrows pointing to it and
repeat until you've hit every step there
are two things here that are tricky to
translate for a robot first how do you
keep track of the information and second
what do you do if there are multiple
options at the same time for the first
challenge a convenient way for machines
to store information is in a table in
this case you can have hedge lists every
step in the headers of both the rows and
columns then he can go through the rows
one at a time on the schematic what
points to mix both shake and titrate so
hedge should make a mark in both of
their columns you can do the same for
every row one at a time to make a table
like this of course the full table will
be much bigger
like a human hedge we'll also want to
start from one of the steps that has no
arrows pointing to it which is the same
as having no marks in its row if there's
more than one a convenient way to choose
is to pick the one that's alphabetically
earliest though other selection methods
can work just as well
next hedge can add that step to his
running order list delete its entire
column from the table thus removing all
the times it was a dependency and loop
back to the start because there are no
circular references in the graph each
time we get here there will be at least
one step with no remaining dependencies
hedge can add the alphabetically
earliest to his running order list
remove it from the table and loop back
to the start again so now we have a
working loop and it'll run through all
the elements in our table until none are
left hedge drifts back and forth over
the schematics and soon he starts
spitting out instructions which ethic
uses to configure the assembly lines
with the three working together they
churn out thousands of doses of the cure
in no time
ethic finally plucks the note of memory
from it's holding field and trips the
alarm within seconds bots are everywhere
[Music]
as ethic Falls in shock the note
restores not only her own memories but
reveals the last missing pieces of the
puzzle ethic built hedge with a singular
purpose to construct a maze that would
protect the world machine from a corrupt
government but in her haste she made a
critical mistake she forgot to set the
condition that would end the loop which
told hedge how large the maze should be
so hedge built and built until he could
build no longer and then he was
conflicted he had to build a maze but he
couldn't build further without hurting
people or flying over the Bradbury er
both forbidden by his programming so he
wandered the land and searched for a
solution until he happened upon the note
of power the note of creation and the
note of memory he recognized their true
collective power to grant self-awareness
to those who lack it with all three he'd
be able to change his programming and
fulfill his drive to transform the
entire world into a giant maze it
wouldn't be easy the nodes had
safeguards to prevent robots from taking
and using them but if hedge could find
the right human and manipulate her with
the promise of a heroic quest well that
would be a different story a very
different story
[Music]
continue the adventure in episode 10 of
think like a coder or restart the
journey with episode 1 and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]